pour cité de la gastronomie et de la
malbouffe cette deuxième place au
classement du plus grand nombre de fast
food par habitant et tonnes jusqu'aux
premiers intéressés les consommateurs je
pensais plus que ce serait jean brunhes
gilles marseille ou un truc comme ça à
tours pour moi c'est assez les bourses
enfin ça va mais plus des restaurants
gastro et tous les coups bas ça m'étonne
on voit souvent les gènes dans les
restaurants manger des choses assez
bonne quand même mais du coup c'est vrai
que ça m'étonne bassam et aime beaucoup
cette étude prend en compte uniquement
les seize principales chaînes de
restauration rapide de france mettant de
côté les indépendants 24 fast food sont
répertoriés à tour mais il y en a en
réalité beaucoup plus ce kebab par
exemple tourner tous les jours à plein
régime car la demande est forte
c'est normal il ya pas mal de tibérine à
plus de 20000 à tort alors c'est pour ça
et en plus le club c'est à portée de
tout le monde ça on peut le manger vite
chez les spécialistes de la gastronomie
met le holà
ces résultats sont à relativiser mesurer
la malbouffe ne se résume pas à
comptabiliser le nombre d'enseignés de
restauration rapide mais fluctuations
dans cette danse classement ça a tenu à
l'ouverture à la fermeture d'une chaîne
de french tacos c'est un peu déterminé
ce classement alors ça prouve bien
d'ailleurs que ça tient à rien fait non
parce que quelques restaurants suffisent
à changer le classement de quatre cinq
six places pas d'inquiétude non plus du
côté des restaurateurs en cuisine
florent martin continue de croire à la
bonne réputation de la gastronomie
tourangelle regardez mon poisson est en
train de finir de cuire
il est frais est-ce que c'est pas là le
secret de faire oublier ce classement de
continuer à faire maison et de faire
voir qu'on est là dijon et lyon les deux
autres cité de la gastronomie ne sont
pas non plus épargnés par la malbouffe
elles occupent respectivement les 15e et
16e place du classement